so our actions that seem small so small
scale military actions
can have uh
can have dire detrimental effects to the
whole Space Program like Global Space
Program oh yeah it can affect everything
and everyone including the like
including satellites oh yeah especially
satellites like that's the well I mean
the good and the bad thing is the good
thing is a lot of satellites don't
operate in low earth orbit like a lot of
uh the the ones that we use day to day a
lot of them are
and medium earth orbit like the GPS or
their geostationary which are way way
out there and because of that they they
won't really ever de-orbit or like it'll
take you know Millennia to deorbit
because you know just because
something's in space doesn't mean it's
there forever especially like in low
earth orbit the atmosphere doesn't just
suddenly stop it's not like you hit the
carbon line 100 kilometers and also
there's zero atmosphere the atmosphere
just slowly tapers you know you can
experience that yourself as you climb
them out and you slowly realize there's
less and less air you just keep going
and just because you're in space 200 300
kilometers up there's still Trace
molecules you know there's the
occasional oxygen molecule there's the
occasional nitrogen molecule and so that
is actually drag so as a spacecraft in
low earth orbit depending on its
altitude will take anywhere from
five years to five months to deorbit you
know or two months or one month like
depending on its orbit or its altitude
we'll have some parasitic drag still and
slowly throughout time slow down which
lowers its orbit which drags it down
more lowers this orbit et cetera et
cetera until it reenters so if we end up
with uh some kind of catastrophic event
where the entire low earth orbit is you
know has been inundated and blown up
it'll take months for the first band you
know to clear up it'll take years for
something like Beyond there's charts you
know people have all this stuff
available you shouldn't look it's
terrifying by the way but this is really
the but again the caveat is for the most
part the low earth orbit stuff would
clear up within years so we could get
back to doing some more with it like
starlink stuff would probably be able to
be re and you know we could kind of redo
it and build up from the ground up again
GPS wouldn't be wiped out and our
geostationary satellites wouldn't be
wiped up but the scary thing is we
wouldn't be able to relaunch and replace
new things because we're stuck we're not
going to fly through that debris field
you know
and we avoid that by avoiding military
actions in space and these days like
there's more and more uh requirements
and and legislation and especially
trying to get International
collaboration on having end-of-life
plans for satellites so that satellites
especially those in low earth orbit have
like drag devices to increase them once
they're done they literally pull like
even just a ribbon like a silly little
like you know 40 foot long ribbon will
sit there and it'll slowly it or it can
speed up its re-entry process by months
or years or whatever so we're starting
to see that this is now an importance
there's a really cool company called
Stoke Aerospace out in Washington is one
of these launch provisor providers
that's really looking not into just
trying to be the next you know SpaceX
launch company they're really seeing
satellite uh bringing stuff down from
space is actually being especially right
now we have all of these hundreds and
thousands of satellites being launched
every year someone at some point is
probably gonna have to do some cleanup
and so they're looking at being one of
those companies to do that